[Music]
anybody here enjoy pokemon
yeah i used to love the pumpkin i enjoy
a nice charizard myself did you guys
did you guys all have pokemon cards
my cousin still has a bunch still in
like those little sleeves and stuff
hoping they're going to be more valuable
one day even though they're valuable now
my hoarder mother has them somewhere but
she doesn't know where
i'm glad you ended with the hard er
because once you started with [ __ ] i
was like
my dude my horror mother is a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right so there's a man out there who
buys
he buys this 13 000 pokemon card is it
charizard
it is a charizard
but it gets lost in the mail no oh what
the [ __ ]
did they send it in a regular envelope
it should be overnighted dude what the
[ __ ] in a charizard envelope
a charizard inside rare pokemon verified
in the mail yeah i didn't get lost so
this man was left devastated after
splashing out thirteen thousand dollars
for this pokemon card for it to get lost
in the post right collector paul
gallagher from atlanta buys and sells
pokemon cards and says he can usually
earn ten thousand dollars or more a
month and he bought this rare charizard
card to sell on but after he posted it
out to the buyer uh in december it got
lost in the post which is crazy because
remember the [ __ ] uh the trains that
got jacked in december yeah
i also lost a bunch of random amazon
packages and stuff like that oh [ __ ]
yeah
nothing ever happened because you know
there's no yeah what can they do
but dude you send a 13 000 package you
get it insured every [ __ ] time yeah
right yeah that's true and then you
don't send it regular parcel i mean
you do it like overnight next day with a
tracking and [ __ ] you make sure that
someone shows up and signs for it
somebody was cheaping out man that's
what happened yeah yeah this guy's 13
g's and he looks into making how he's
like
i don't know what his 180 insurance
thing
he's like it's a scam never get
insurance
yeah dude it's it's free money for them
[ __ ] them it's their little racket yeah
they also rock it
well dude
i paid to fly out here and they're like
do you want to protect your [ __ ] and i'm
like [ __ ] no yeah that's different
but if that ticket was thirteen thousand
dollars i would say [ __ ] yeah like yeah
i'm already spending thirteen thousand
why not the 180. you know so you know
something crazy is that reminds me of uh
like i heard there was a scam when you
get your green card that they
intentionally like say it got lost in
the mail the first time and then you
have to pay to get it reissued because
it happened to my girl when she when
smack got her green card it just got
lost in the mail and then the the uh
office was like oh well for just a small
fee we can get another one sent out
and i hear they do it every time it's
like a hundred something bucks oh
they're nickel and diming yes dude
so there's gotta be some kind of [ __ ]
where they're like they kind of know
what the [ __ ] in that envelope and
they're like yeah yeah [ __ ] pokemon
nerds all work at the postal service
well dude that's like when you know when
playstation and xbox were first coming
out all those packages kept getting
ripped off and they're sorry lost in the
mail yeah that's a good racket though
things happen sometimes when you mail
things
we got to stop having that person be the
spokesman
hi guys i'm here to announce
more stuff went missing
i think um mail tampering or stealing or
like even [ __ ] up those blue boxes i
think it's like a federal offense it's
like hard [ __ ] core i'm dealing with
something like that because i sent out a
laptop
and when i sent it out you buy insurance
no so that was the thing and i never got
offered to buy anything because the box
was big so they came around the side to
grab it and i already have like a a tag
like packing slip on it and everything
like that and they're like oh okay we'll
take care of this for you i was like oh
that's it like i don't have to like scan
anything nope you're good i'll take care
of it don't worry i was like are you
sure she's like yeah yeah you're cool
it's like all right and i left like
three weeks passed the person never got
it so i will back into the post office
like oh that's not our issue you can
call the thing and then she tried to
tell me oh you didn't do that here that
you did it in san gabriel i'm like no
that's my return address that's my home
i didn't send it from here i came in and
brought it to you no i don't believe i
don't think you did i was like how are
you gonna tell me i came here on my
lunch break and sent this it's like all
right you have to call the
the the number so i call them and i try
to file a claim and when i say that i
was like i want to make sure like no one
stole my
you know package like it's an expensive
laptop it's like a 1500 laptop he's like
yeah um give me one minute i was like
okay and then you just here
maybe hung up on you yeah i did the us
postal service usbs this was all this
pack that is federally offensive yeah
so i was talking to my friend he was
like it's a federal crime if like they
stole your
if they find out that someone stole your
laptop it's a federal crime so i'm
dealing with all that literally
currently it's a federal crime but
they're not to [ __ ] get caught i know
that's what sucks because we've heard
that all our lives that like hey [ __ ]
with the meals of federal crime hey so
is insider trading yeah but who gets in
trouble right yeah
give me a break i've never heard of
anybody like what would you do what are
you in for man he's i'm a male jockey
i'm a porch pirate all those people that
steal amazon package from the porch like
the cops don't [ __ ] chase them none
of them yeah no [ __ ] didn't even file
a report
have you guys been watching the glitter
bomb guy he makes
and then it's like stink bombs and [ __ ]
i love watching these [ __ ] get
covered in god damn it god there's so
much glitter
[Laughter]
and then now it like sprays crazy
so he said that uh we're talking
thousands of dollars that card we're
talking about cost me 13 000 to buy it
not only did i lose my initial
investment but i lost the money that the
customer spent they refunded him that
money
so last week the united states postal
service got in touch to tell him that
the card had disappeared they explained
they didn't get back to me uh until
march 25th and declared it was missing
and here's 200 for your 13 000 card and
good luck
dude you know what hurts me the most is
just imagining some lincoln heights
crack head just busting open the
envelope and going
and they're just pokemon cards gone
forever it's like dude that's just
probably happening right now it's just
like chilling somewhere they throw
the card down and start eating the
package
that whole train yard is where all the
packages got destroyed and there was a
bunch of packages that weren't even
destroyed that were still there they're
just open no not even open like some
we're just still packages should we go
down there and see what we can find i
think it's too late now
there's a bunch of guys eating charizard
packaging
that's actually by barbell
yeah it's pretty close dude i remember
when um you know we all had pokemon
cards in school and [ __ ] i think we all
did in this room yeah for sure uh so so
you know we have those binders and i'll
never forget the day that i got out i
got out of pokemon cards it was um i was
there with my binder and i got this dude
that i knew named anthony across from me
and he's like oh steve let me check that
out and there's this really like
attractive chick across from us and
she's like what what the hell are you
guys doing and
i'm like
oh you know this is this thing called
pokemon cards and she's like i know what
that is she's like i didn't know you did
that steve and i was like
i don't anymore you know
knocked out of the head [ __ ] this [ __ ]
i'm never doing this [ __ ] again
went home just handed to my brothers i'm
like [ __ ] this whole thing you severed
your emotional attachment today
i didn't know you did it steve was like
my head like
what happened to me how did i let myself
get here
so if you feel like you're a bit you're
scarred for life from pokemon cards or
no no well now it's you know it's fine
because everyone talks about it
nostalgically so you got over the trauma
i got all the traffic that was
anti-pussy behavior yeah exactly that
was personal cockblock moves well that's
when he was [ __ ] himself i
looked myself in the mirror and i was
like oh my god i'm i'm the [ __ ] right
now
i didn't know you did i didn't know
it's funny because that's that used to
happen to me with anime a lot where
girls would go like oh that's funny this
one persian girl was like i didn't know
you were into that stuff and i was like
i think how do i [ __ ] say something i
said well yeah i mean it's just like an
asian culture thing it's not like
she goes oh i can see that
and when you go to a room it's probably
full of miyazaki [ __ ]
and then you're like oh wait you're
trying to connect with me
[Laughter]
thank you asian culture oh you know it's
just a part of the culture you know yeah
and i know there's people who are like
look man there's nothing more [ __ ] made
than letting a chick change you dude i'm
like whatever dude
when did you get laid last okay how old
were you i was like 12 or something
dude at that age anytime a chick says
anything to you you're like what you get
you get your your feelings hurt over
here oh dude it's amazing is this your
hand sweating
i just loved
all those nerdy things like so i think
so much more than like the possible sex
that i would just
double down like this one time i was on
tour when i was like doing lmfao tour
and then i have my laptop on the tour
bus and then i brought a girl on with me
and then she like opened my computer and
i still had my sims like loaded up
so i would play sims incessantly during
tour so everybody be [ __ ] making out
and [ __ ] and i'm just like i'm building
a little home
and she's like a little three-bedroom
and she's like wait and then she saw i
don't i think she was like german or she
didn't really understand
and i they don't build buildings there
yeah i just i just closed it i was like
yeah you know that's not for you
it's like you're hiding your porn yeah i
love anytime this man starts telling a
story about somebody else i'm like i
hope they're gonna make it
he's like i'm on the bus she comes up
behind me and i'm like oh no she's gonna
trip and fall she's gonna have a heart
attack she's just gonna [ __ ] be dying
they're always gonna die
something's gonna happen
crap is gonna crash she makes it through
this story
and i never saw her again
no sometimes they live sometimes they
live
i hope we make it
i know
we just become a part of ryan's stories
one day on another talk show no dude
when i'm like a grandpa i'm like i used
to be on podcasters these guys they were
great
did they did they die too
they sure did
he's the luckiest survivor he's
padlocked everyone around him
he's the guy who's like why me why did
you pick me god
i'm the guy at the end of saving private
ryan they're just crying at the graves
that's not funny that's sad my family
all my this freaking family of 12 behind
me just let him do it let him cry and
you're the same age and you can't die
and you're an immortal you're a vampire
everyone you know it's just you and
keanu reeves left that's it
lives to tell the tale
[Music]
you